[Música]
ser loco y pobre
además solo
hoy
acá vamos a hablar de arte y salud
mental
yo les digo que describan la mirada de
un hijo
o que dibujen el rostro de un ser amado
inmediatamente aparecen en nosotros
imágenes cargadas de afectividad con
esas imágenes cargadas de afectividad
vamos a trabajar porque les voy a hacer
una propuesta
y es que dibujen su propia mirada hoy
ustedes tienen en la entrada les han
dado una bolsita si tomen la bolsita por
favor
ahí tienen una hoja en blanco y una
lapicera
encontraron ahí está la hoja en blanco y
la lapicera
van a dibujar su mirada hoy
como en su mirada hoy es una mirada
feliz incisiva penetrante es una mirada
enamorada
dibujo el formato de mis ojos dibujarlo
dibujarlo el formato de mis ojos de cada
uno de ustedes
su iris
su pupila
sus pestañas
sus cejas
como es mi mirada hoy
a ver estos ojos estas pestañas estas
hijas pero sobre todo la intención en la
mirada eso es lo que cuenta hoy
todos
sentimos el vacío frente a la hoja en
blanco
todos sentimos ese vacío que hacemos
ahora todos sentimos el vacío frente al
hoja en blanco pero también hay toda una
posibilidad que se despliega de traer
imágenes cargadas de vivencias afectos
resonancias e historias
porque en la historia de la humanidad
siempre ha habido imágenes las imágenes
nos acompañan desde el 40 mil antes de
cristo en el paleolítico superior
el arte permite que seamos esto que
somos hoy
hombres y mujeres sensibles y que
podamos mirar desde una percepción
estética
pero se preguntarán por qué arte y salud
mental porque cuando hablamos de salud
mental las primeras palabras que
aparecen son salud enfermedad
y sufrimiento
imposibilidad sobre todo en posibilidad
y lo que nosotros podemos evidenciar al
cabo de tantos años de trabajo en
nuestro dispositivo es que el arte nos
posibilita y nos iguala porque podemos
trabajar con otro lenguaje que no es
necesariamente la palabra nosotros
podemos trabajar desde el cuerpo desde
el movimiento desde la textura desde la
imagen desde el color entonces los
sentidos se multiplican
el arte también favorece y posibilita
crear algo que no existe por fuera del
realizador la persona toma la realidad y
se transforma transforma la realidad y
se transforma
y el arte también permite que podamos
atravesar la barrera del ver para
adentrarnos en el mirar
hoy aquí
voy a hablarles de un proyecto de
extensión de la universidad nacional de
mar del plata- llamado colectivo
crisálida arte salud mental e
intervención comunitaria
este proyecto tiene ya unos 10 años
aproximadamente
porque porque permite evidenciar la
problemática del sufrimiento mental y la
situación de vulnerabilidad de las
personas que la padecen
franco basaglia psiquiatra italiano
escribió un libro que se llama la
condena de ser loco y pobre y nosotros a
eso parafraseándolo en el inicio de la
charla agregábamos y solos porque la
mayoría de las personas con las que
trabajamos
o no tienen una familia continente o
están tutelados por el poder judicial o
están en situación de vulnerabilidad
social o familiar o económica
colectivo crisálida está conformado está
construido somos un grupo de
profesionales y estudiantes en forma
interdisciplinaria de los campos del
arte y de la salud mental
crisálida proviene del griego christos
que significa oro como metáfora porque
es en el interior de la persona donde
ocurre todo un proceso de transformación
para devenir en la mariposa que surgirá
nosotros trabajamos con el oro con la
potencia con el tesoro personal
desde los diferentes talleres artísticos
lo que se hace es se ponen en juego
creativo esas potencias esas
posibilidades que todos tenemos
y acá les hago una pregunta
qué pasa cuando nadie nos ve
sabemos que somos construidos y
reconstruidos desde la mirada
qué pasa
cuando una persona solo es su historia
clínica
o solo es su diagnóstico
o su imposibilidad qué pasa en la
subjetividad de una persona
invisibilizada
y regresando a las imágenes que ustedes
tienen en sus manos
levanten por favor sus propias miradas
dibujadas como esta y sostengan la en la
mano ahí está
en el encuentro con la mirada del otro
que me construyó me sostengo y me
visibilizó
regresando a las miradas nuestra propia
qué dice de nosotros
que espera y que refleja
y ahora les voy a pedir otro favor más
que levanten su mirada y se la pasen al
compañero de la derecha
pásale la mirada ya está así todos
tenemos una nueva mirada a esta genial
muy bien
derecha
izquierda también puede estar a
cualquiera
esta nueva mirada
qué dice de nosotros
que espera y que refleja
y acá nosotros podemos marcar
paralelismos con el arte porque el arte
también permite reflejar nos despejarnos
y transformarnos y también ver la
transformación de una persona
la historia de juan
juan llegó hace aproximadamente unos dos
años
para el mes de julio bajo de un remís
trucho acompañado de su esposa y de sus
dos hijos así llegó
daba pasitos cortos
no levantaba los pies del piso
su cuerpo se balanceaba
y su voz era un murmullo
su esposa lo llevaba del brazo y un
brazo su hijo del otro y por la espalda
del otro hijo
así llegó y nos contaron su historia
porque él no podía hacerlo
juan un hombre pobre sin recursos
con depresión
que entré a una institución psiquiátrica
hablando y caminando
y sale a los ocho meses en silla de
ruedas y balbuceando
y aquí
pregunta
qué pasa cuando el poder médico
hegemónico se ejerce sobre alguien que
no puede defenderse
una persona que pintaba que escribía que
tenía su quinta termina transformado en
una sombra de lo que fue en un vacío de
sus potencialidades
es que existen prácticas abusivas que
utilizan hoy día son malas prácticas
estas prácticas abusivas que utilizan
hoy día la medicación como chaleco
químico y que no ven al otro como sujeto
sino como objeto
también podemos decir
que hay medicación de última generación
por ahí con menos efectos colaterales
pero que no son accesibles para las
personas vulnerables y hoy tampoco el
transporte es accesible para las
personas vulnerables
nosotros no sabíamos si vamos a poder
ayudar a juan no lo sabíamos no sabíamos
si nuestro dispositivo iba a serle útil
pero lo vimos vimos su mirada sus ojos
vivos e inteligentes y decidimos
intentarlo
cabe aclarar que funcionamos en un
centro cultural recuperado de la ciudad
de mar del plata- llamado américa libre
que funcionamos en un primer piso
que para subir hay que subir dos
escaleras empinadas entonces habíamos
construido un dispositivo que era una
silla de madera donde juan se sentaba y
entre cuatro hombres los subían
como en la sillita de oro
inicialmente su cuerpo se balanceaba y
luego en el espacio de cuerpo empezó a
dar pasitos cortos acompañado por una
coordinadora en cada brazo y luego por
una
y después sostuvo el lápiz con su mano
el pulso se afianzó y pudo pintar
y un día escribió un texto
y otro día lo leyó y otro sonrío
y es que el arte posibilita genera
empoderamiento
hablamos de un arte que emociona y que
transforma
nuestro dispositivo aparece como máquina
deseante al decir del filósofo del es
que establece líneas de fuga creativas y
en esas líneas de fuga nosotros
trabajamos y también trabajamos en la
construcción de nuevas miradas como las
que ustedes tienen en sus manos
y es desde el arte
desde las prácticas artísticas concretas
que se construyen formas más saludables
de resistencia
[Música]
basta
de amazon
[Música]
un beso
murcia
[Música]
tanto
tú
[Música]
cuándo
bien
qué
[Música]
de todo
también
[Música]
y
no más
yo hablé con
[Música]
sí
nunca más
[Música]
no más
[Aplausos]
[Música]